you've come here the United States  you're visiting what is your impression  of America what's the first thing that  strikes you well it's a it's a great  country we love it and we started yeah  well we started from Boston and you know  we knew you're also from Boston so you  would drop your name here and they're  like we want a pizza but by the way  we're going into Connors show so make it  really nice extra good and and when they  heard Conan they said oh that's the guy  who works with Sona right yeah yeah Sona  is like big in Armenian communities I  brought my sister Sona and she became  the huge star she understand that people  in Armenia like she's a goddess there  now is that right that's right yeah yeah  you know what what you are in Armenia  and my grandma said oh yeah sona's  bodyguard picking up our million really  good you know she saw the thing why  would anyone think I was anybody's  bodyguard  you